REPEAT THAT I AM MATCHING
EVERYBODY IN THE ROOM HEARD.
THERE'S THOSE WHO ARE LISTENING
ELSEWHERE.
SUBCOMMITTEE -- FIVE THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY IN
THE JUDICIARY.
WILL NOW CONVENE WE ARE STARTING
WITH PART A WHICH IS THE SECTION
ON THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES.
WE HAVE FIVE ISSUES UNDER THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
THAT ARE VOTE ONLY.
AND THEN WE FOLLOW THAT WITH TWO
ISSUES THAT WE ARE -- GOING TO
DISCUSS.
SO IF I COULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION
ON THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS.
EXCELLENT.
TIME WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
VOTE ONLY ITEMS IF WE COULD CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE AND SKEWS ME YOU
MUST ESTABLISH.
THE CORN FIRST ROW ROW COLIN
WHO'S PRESSING ENTER SKINNER
HERE SENATOR MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
SENATOR BILL.
ALRIGHT SO WE HAVE A ROLL CALL.
BUT WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FIRST -- SET OF ISSUES ISSUES
ONE THROUGH -- FIVE NOW YOU CAN
CALL THE ROLL IN THOSE SENATOR
SKINNER.
BY SENATOR MORLOCK SENATE ABOUT.
RIGHT EXCELLENT SO NOW WE WILL
GO.
TO THE DISCUSSION ITEMS IN THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES AND
THE FIRST ISSUE IS OUR DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS AND RESPONSE.
AND LET ME BEFORE WE EVEN BEGIN
THAT DISCUSSION.
CLARIFY THAT ON THAT ISSUE SIX
ON PAGE -- SEVEN THREE PAGE.
NO AND READ OUR CORRECTIONS
GOING OUT WHAT TEACHERS STAFF
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
RIGHT SO BEFORE WE START THE
DISCUSSION ON PAGE.
NINE OF YOUR MATERIALS THAT IS
THE STAFF'S ANALYSIS.
ON THE BOTTOM OF THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION.
THERE WAS A ADDITION ERROR.
AND SO THE ACTUAL DOLLAR AMOUNT
WERE THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
SAYS IT CURRENTLY STATES.
PROOF FIVE POINT EIGHT NINE FOUR
MILLION.
THAT NUMBER IS. TO BE ACTUALLY
CORRECTED IN IS. SIX POINT SIX
OH FIVE MILLION SWEET STRIKE OUT
THE FIVE POINT.
EIGHT NINE FOUR AND REPLACE WITH
THE CORRECT NUMBER WHICH IS SIX
POINT.
SIX OH FIVE ALL RIGHT SO NOW WE
HAVE THE ERROR CORRECTED.
WE WILL -- START OUR DISCUSSION.
THANK YOU PLEASE SERVE --
INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND PROCEED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CHRIS COKE
AND I AM THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES AND
WITH ME I HAVE ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR.
CAPITA STOUT FIRMAR FINANCE AND
ADMINISTRATION WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ACTIONS ON OUR EARLIER
PROPOSALS AND FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY ON TWO CRITICAL PROPOSALS
THAT WE HAVE IN SUPPORT OF
PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT.
AS YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA HAS
EXPERIENCED DEVASTATING
DISASTERS OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS AND THESE REQUEST WILL
PROVIDE THE MUCH NEEDED FUNDING
AND RESOURCES TO HELP ADDRESS
THOSE NEEDS BEFORE DURING AND
AFTER DISASTERS.
SINCE TWENTY TWELVE CALIFORNIA
HAS RECEIVED FOURTEEN FEDERAL
MAJOR DISASTER DECLARATIONS AND
DOZENS OF OTHERS STATE ONLY
PROCLAMATIONS.
FIRE MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE
GRANTS.
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN CALENDAR
YEAR ALONE FOR THE LARGEST
DEADLY ESTAMOS DAMAGING FIRES IN
THE STATE'S HISTORY.
I MEAN OVER A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
LIVES TO STORING ALMOST. TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND STRUCTURES.
AND BURNING OVER ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION ACRES.
WE BELIEVE THAT THESE BECAUSE AS
PROPOSALS ARE CRITICAL TO HELP
ADDRESS THOSE GAPS.
OUR SYSTEM DIRECTOR TYPE OF THE
STYLE WILL PROVIDE YOU A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THOSE TWO PROPOSALS
AND THEN WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU.
SO THE FIRST PROPOSAL IS OUR
DISASTER PLANNING PREPAREDNESS
AND RESPONSE PROPOSAL IT'S
REQUESTING APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS OF
GENERAL FUND EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FOUR THOUSAND A FEDERAL
TRUST FUND AND NINETY FOUR
POSITIONS TO SUPPORT.
RUN ACTIVITIES RELATED TO
DISASTER PLANNING PREPAREDNESS
AND RESPONSE AND THREE SEPARATE
PROMS.
THE FIRST PRONG IS TO ADDRESS
OUR STUDY STATE WORK.
THIS HAS TWO COMPONENTS WE HAVE
A CONVERSION OF THIRTY SIX
POSITIONS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
LIMITED TERM THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED ARE ADDRESSED SEEN
ONGOING WORKLOAD THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO CONVERT TO PERMANENT.
THE SECOND PORTION OF THE
PROPOSAL IS FORTY NEW POSITIONS
TO ADDRESS WORKLOAD THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED THAT WE HAVE.
BUT THESE WOULD ADDRESS GAPS
THAT WE HAVE IDENTIFIED DURING
THE RECENT DISASTER RESPONSE
RECOVERY EFFORTS.
THE SECOND PRONG OF THIS
PROPOSAL IS THAT MISSION TASKING
FUN THIS INCLUDES A TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR APPROPRIATION.
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES TO PROVIDE
FUNDING TO STATE AGENCIES THAT
THAT MISSION TASK BY CALLAWAY
YES TO PERFORM RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY EFFORTS -- FOR DECLARE
DISASTERS.
THE POSITIONS ARE REQUIRED TO
HELP TRACK THE MISSION
[inaudible]
THE MISSION TASKING ASSIGNMENTS
AND ELIGIBLE COSTS.
SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE.
FULL COST RECOVERY FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THE THIRD COMPONENT OF THIS IS
OUR CONTINUITY AND SEARCH
CAPACITY WE'RE REQUESTING SIX
POSITIONS TO HELP DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT A STATEWIDE DISASTER
RESERVE CORPS RESOURCE POOL.
THIS WOULD DEVELOP A POOL OF
POTENTIAL.
STATE EMPLOYEES THAT WE COULD
CALL UPON DURING TIMES OF
DISASTERS IT WOULDN'T JUST BE
CALLAWAY YES IT WOULD BE A STATE
WIDE RESOURCE THAT COULD BE USED.
WITHIN MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS AND
WOULD HELP TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THOSE RESOURCES AS WE NEED THEM
RATHER THAN.
CONTINUOUSLY GOING OUT ASKING
FOR TEN HELD POSITIONS OR
GETTING OUR REYES AND IT WOULD
HAVE A COMPONENT THAT WOULD BE
TRACKING THEIR TRAINING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE ELIGIBLE.
AND THEY'RE PREPARED AND READY
TO RESPOND TO HELP US RESPOND TO
THE DISASTERS.
AND WHEN WE SEARCH.
IT WOULD PROVIDE THAT LEVEL OF
RESOURCES TO APPROPRIATELY
ADDRESS THAT SURGE DURING THE
DISASTER.
AND SO IF YOU HAVE ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS.
I DO THE WELL FIRST IN THE IN
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION.
POINTS OUT THAT.
THE PERMANENT POSITIONS BEING
REQUESTED FOR THE DISASTER
RESERVE CORPS.
COULD POTENTIALLY BE FULFILLED
BY THIS MISSION -- TASKING --
TWENTY MILLION THAT'S BEING
REQUESTED.
AND IS SO IT'S UNCLEAR REALLY
THE DIFFERENCE AND ESPECIALLY.
THE THE THERE'S LITTLE LANGUAGE
AT LEAST IN THE ITEM REGARDING
THE TWENTY MILLION FOR THE
MISSION TASKINGS SO I GUESS I'D
LIKE TO KNOW -- MORE
SPECIFICALLY. FOR WHAT PURPOSES
THAT TWENTY MILLION WOULD BE
USED.
SURE SO -- SO THE TWENTY MILLION
MILLION WOULD BE IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE CAN WEIGH
IN A LITTLE MORE ON THIS WOULD
BE -- TO INSURE THAT THE FUNDING
IS AVAILABLE FOR THOSE STATE
AGENCIES WHO FORWARD RESPOND TO
THOSE MISSION ASSIGNMENTS.
SO AND HE STAFF ASSOCIATED WITH
THE TRACKING OF THAT ACTIVITY
NOT JUST -- FOR YES BUT FOR
EVERY STATE DEPARTMENT TO ENSURE
THAT THEIR DOCUMENTATION IS
COMPLETE ACCURATE AND SUBMITTED
TIMELY SO THAT WE ENSURE THAT WE
ARE MAXIMIZING THAT.
THOSE FEDERAL FUNDS COMING BACK
INTO KEPT CALIFORNIA SO THERE'S
A PART OF THE OUT REACH THERE'S
A PART OF TRACKING
ACCOUNTABILITY DOCUMENTATION SO
THE MIDDLE TRACKING AND THEN
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO RECONCILE THOSE FUNDS.
THE SIX POSITIONS ON THE SURGE
CAPACITY OR DIFFERENT
CLASSIFICATIONS THAT WE WOULD --
PLAN TO UTILIZE TO ESTABLISH
THIS CADRE OF A POTENTIAL
APPLICANTS AND EMPLOYEES THAT
COULD BE BROUGHT ON FOR A
DISASTER NOT JUST FOR CALLAWAY
YES BUT FOR CAL FIRE FOR CAL
RECYCLE FOR ANY. ONE OF THE MANY
STATE DEPARTMENTS THAT WE RELY
UPON TO PERFORM THEIR MISSION TO
EITHER BACK FILL THERE'S MISSION
CRITICAL STEADY STATE WORK -- SO
THERE'S A THERE'S AN ASSESSMENT
OF THEIR CAPABILITIES EDUCATION --
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO WORK AND
TRAVEL AND THEN BEING ABLE TO
MAINTAIN THAT AND ONE TABLET THE
MENTIONED THE ASPECT OF THE
TRAINING THAT IS ONE PIECE THAT
IS CRITICAL TO ENSURING THAT WE
MAINTAIN CONTINUITY WITH THOSE
POTENTIAL APPLICANTS.
THAT THERE WE HAVE TRAINING
AVAILABLE TO THEM ONLINE WE HVE
WEBINARS WITH THEM TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE MAINTAINING CONTACT
SO WHEN THE EARTHQUAKE HAPPENS
WHEN THE NEXT FIRE SIEGE HAPPENS.
THAT WERE ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY UP
CALL THOSE FOLKS BRING THEM IN
AND BE ABLE TO PLACE THEM
WITHOUT HAVING TO GO THROUGH AND
LOSE TIME DURING THOSE CRITICAL
DAYS AND WEEKS OF THE EVENT.
WELL I AM SUPPORTIVE OF THE
STATE.
OF OUR IMPROVING OUR ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY TRACK THE EXPENDITURE
SO THAT WE CAN SUBMIT THEM TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHICH IS
OUR RIGHT TO DO AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT IS AS
COMPLETE AS POSSIBLE BUT THERE
JUST SEEMS TO BE A LOT OF
OVERLAP.
BETWEEN THE TWENTY MILLION
TRACKING MISSION AND THIS --
OTHER PERMANENT POSITIONS
REGARDING THE RESERVE CORPS SO
THAT THAT'S MY ISSUE BUT LET ME
SEE IF MY COLLEAGUES SEVENTY
QUESTIONS AND WE CAN LEAD TO
PERMANENT FINANCE -- RESPOND IN
ADDITION TO THE STAFF PRESENTE
CENTER MOORLACH THANK YOU
MANAGER -- WAS IT HOGAN.
COKE COKE I'M SORRY I HEARD
THIRTY YEARS FROM -- WE'RE AT
THE END OF THE PROCESS SO I
DON'T HAVE AN ORGANIZATIONAL
CHART -- FOR YES I DON'T HAVE.
A BUSINESS PLAN I DON'T HAVE A
STAFFING REQUEST -- SOME I MEAN
I'M JUST GOING ON FAITH HERE --
SO I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
HOW THE NUMBER OF ADDITIONAL
FULL TIME EQUIVALENTS WAS
DETERMINED -- I WANNA MAKE SURE
THEY THEY'RE WORKING.
SORRY -- BUT I ALSO WANT TO KNOW
HOW HOW WE CAN INTERFACE.
THIS YEAR HAVE THE JOY OF ALSO
BEING ON ENERGY.
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS AND
MEETING WITH THE CEOS OF OUR
INDEPENDENT -- IN THE BILLION ON
THE UTILITIES -- THEY ARE
WORKING REALLY HARD ON IT'S A
YOU KNOW PUTTING CAMERAS AROUND
THEIR TERRITORY PUTTING UP.
WIND -- DETECTION DEVICES --
THERE'S JUST SO MUCH THAT
THEY'RE DOING.
AT LEAST IN MY PART OF THE STATE --
SO I'M JUST WONDERING ARE WE I
CANNOT MAKE THE ARGUMENT THAT
WERE HIRING JUST ENOUGH.
THAT WE CAN WORK WITH WHAT'S
BEING DONE BY THE PRIVATE SECTOR
SO THAT WE COVER AT LEAST THE
WILDFIRE ASPECT THAT AND FOCUSED
ON RIGHT NOW.
JUST JUST HELP ME OUT SURE IS SO --
pCORRECTLY -- AS FAR AS THE
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE METRICS OF
THIS PERMANENT -- FULL TIME
STAFF THAT WERE REQUESTING AS
FAR AS THE WORKLOAD THAT THEY
ARE REQUIRED TO DO AND HOW WERE --
ENVISIONING THAT WORK PLAN
PLAYING OUT OF ONE OF THE ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO OUR DIRECTOR.
IS THAT THERE ARE METRICS IN
PLACE TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE IN
FACT EVALUATING HOW EFFECTIVE
OUR RESPONSES AND ARE TRACKING --
IT IS AS FAR AS WHAT WE'RE BEING
ABLE -- TO REIMBURSE GET
REIMBURSED BACK FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WHAT -- YOU KNOW
DECREASE OF ANY KIND OF
DISALLOWANCE OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT MIGHT HAVE ON THE
ACCURACY OF OF OUR RESPONSE.
OF THE UTILITIES ARE -- VERY
WELL RESOURCE IN ADDRESSING
THEIR NEEDS AND THEIR GAPS AND
RECORDING VERY CLOSELY WITH THEM
ON MULTIPLE FRIENDS FOR RESPONSE
AND RECOVERY AND AND THE
CRITICAL.
THIS ACTIVITIES THAT HAVE TO
HAPPEN BEFORE AN EVENT TO MAKE
SURE COMMUNITIES ARE READY SO AS
FAR AS METRICS AND
ACCOUNTABILITY -- WE WOULD MOVE
FORWARD WITH HAVING A VERY
DETAILED PLAN KIND OF BUILDING
ON INITIATIVES THAT HAVE BEEN IN
PLACE SUCH AS THE FEDERAL
RESERVE CORPS WHICH HAS BEEN IN
PLACE FOR YEARS AND HOW THEY
IMPLEMENTED THAT AND HOW THE
TRACKS EXCESS -- AS AS WELL AS
OTHER MODELS AS FAR AS
CREDENTIALING PROGRAMS THAT ARE
IN PLACE TO EVALUATE THE
READINESS OF INDIVIDUALS. TO
RESPOND AND BE PREPARED WE DON'T
WANT TO PUT ANYONE IN A
SITUATION AND AS YOU WELL KNOW
OR CAN IMAGINE -- PUTTING
SOMEONE IN AN ONBOARDING THEM
DURING A DISASTER IS VERY
STRESSFUL SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE DO AS MUCH ADVANCED OUT
REGION TRAINING AS POSSIBLE.
ON THE SURGE CAPACITY SIDE AS
FAR AS THE THE POSITIONS
REQUIRED FOR THE COORDINATION
WITH THAT REIMBURSEMENT IS
HANDLED THROUGH A LOT OF
ACCOUNTING A LOT OF ASSESSMENTS
A LOT OF OUT REACH A LOT OF
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION. TO ENSURE
THAT ALL OF THEIR STAFF NOT JUST
TO RESPOND HERS ARE BEING ABLE
TO ORGANIZE THOSE FINANCIAL
PACKAGES ACCURATELY AND WE KNOW
THEY KNOW IN ADVANCE WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S LOOKING FOR
SO THAT WE CAN GET THOSE -- THAT
FUNDING BACK.
AND I'M SURE THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE CAN EXPAND.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AFTER --
ENDED UP A DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
FIRST WE JUST KNOW THAT THIS IS
PART OF THE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
GREATER -- MAY REVISIONS ASTOR
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY PROPOSAL --
YOUR QUESTION ON THE STAFFING
BEING ABLE TO DO BOTH --
COMMISSION TASKING FUND AND ALSO
THE SEARCH CAPACITY NEED -- JUST
KNOW THAT THERE'S A DISTINCTION
BETWEEN THE THE NEED FOR
DEDICATED STAFFING VERSES
DESIGNATED STAFFING IN ADDITION --
AS MISS COOK MENTIONED -- IS A
REALLY DIFFERENT STAFFING
CLASSIFICATIONS ACCOUNTING --
VERSES -- PERSONNEL HER MORE
DISASTER FOCUSED -- IN THE
SEARCH CAPACITY COMPONENTS
REALLY NEEDED -- WHEN THE
BASELINE STAFFING ISN'T THERE
IT'S GOING TO PROVIDE AN
ELEVATED LEVEL OF STAFFING --
AND IT'S REALLY -- A NIMBLE --
INNOVATIVE.
IDEA THAT THE THE STATE'S KIND
OF TAKING FROM FEMA SO -- JUST.
OUT HOW I LEAVE IT AT THAT --
WELL WE WE WERE ALWAYS IN THIS
KIND OF DIFFICULTY WITH -- WHEN
NOT NECESSARILY BLAMING THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT OUR?
OUR CALENDAR STRUCTURE IS SUCH
THAT.
WE GET THE MAY REVISE AND HEY
THAT'S TOTALLY LEGITIMATE FOR
THE BUDGET FROM JANUARY TO THE
BUDGET -- LATER TO HAVE A
LEGITIMATE REVISIONS AND
ADJUSTMENTS BUT THEN WE'RE GIVEN
IT.
AND DUE TO OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
DEADLINE ADDITIONALLY WITH THE
SEVENTY TWO HOUR RULE -- WE NEED
TO ACT PERHAPS BEFORE WE CAN --
YEAH AT LEAST AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
CLOSE BEFORE WE'VE REALLY BEEN
ABLE TO DRILL DOWN. TO FULLY --
TO FEEL FULLY SATISFIED THAT THE
WHAT'S BEING RECOMMENDED AT IS --
YOU KNOW IS.
IT IS AN OVERLAPPING SO -- I
BELIEVE FIVE FOLLOWED -- IF I
SAW LAST NIGHT THE ACTIONS BY
THE ASSEMBLY THAT IF WE TAKE THE
STAF RECOMMENDATION THAT'S HERE
WHICH I SUPPORT.
THIS WILL GO TO CONFERENCE AND
THAT WAY IF THERE IS ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT WILL -- HELP --
WILL ELIMINATE IT FURTHER.
WE CAN -- HALF THAT -- HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION THERE YES REVENGE
YOUR STEVENS WITH BERMAN A
FINANCE -- THE ASSEMBLY
YESTERDAY LEFT THE ISSUE OPEN SO
I'M I'M NOT ACTUALLY SURE WHAT
ACTION THEY'LL BE TAKING YET
OKAY THAT IS IT DEFINITELY BUT
AT LEAST.
AT THE MOMENTWITH WHAT THEY'VE
DONE SO FAR AND IF WE ACT HE
WOULD GO TO CONFERENCE --
ALRIGHT LET'S.
SEE IF THERE'S PUBLIC COMMENT.
ON THE SIDE OF ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ALL RIGHT -- I WOULD
LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
THE STAFF'S RECOMMENDATION AND
AGAIN HI -- MY STAFF AGENDA HAS
THAT CORRECTION OF THE DOLLAR
AMOUNT ON PAGE NINE YOU HAVE IT
AS PAGE EIGHT SO APOLOGIES BUT
IT IS AGAIN.
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION WOULD
BE TO PROVE. SIX POINT SIX OH
FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND IN THE
EIGHT HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR
THOUSAND FEDERAL FIND EIGHTY
EIGHT POSITIONS IN THE ONE TIME
TWENTY MILLION GENERAL FUND. FOR
THE MATCHING MISSION TASKING
ACTIVITIES AND TO REJECT THE
SEVEN HUNDRED ELEVEN THOUSAND
GENERAL FUND AND SIX POSITIONS
FOR THE DISASTER RESERVE CORPS.
OKAY WE'VE GOT A MOTION -- BROKE
OFF AND SKINNER BY SENATOR MORE
NOT.
SENATOR BO.
RIGHT.
NOW WE WILL GO TO ISSUE SEVEN
THE PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT
DOWN RESILIENCY.
AND I AM ASSUMING YOU ALL WILL
BE PRESENTING ON THAT ALSO OKAY
GREAT LET'S GO AHEAD.
SO WE'RE REQUESTING FOR SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OF GENERAL
FUND ONE TIME FUNDING FOR THE
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT DOWN TO
IMPROVE RESILIENCY AT THE
STATE'S CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
IN RESPONSE TO INVESTOR OWNED.
UTILITY LED PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHUT DOWN ACTIONS AND TO PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO COMMUNITIES.
AS SPECIFIC URGENT NEEDS ARE
IDENTIFIED.
THE INVESTOR OWNED.
UTILITIES HAVE SIGNALED THEIR
INTENT TO INCREASE THE USE OF
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT DOWN.
ON THEIR ENERGIZED POWER LINES
TO PREVENT WILDFIRES DURING HIGH
WIND OR OTHER SEVERE EVENTS.
WHICH COULD RESULT IN SEVERE
CASCADING CONSEQUENCES DUE TO
PROLONGED POWER OUTAGES.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMUTE
COMMISSION AND THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES TO COORDINATE
PUBLIC EDUCATION INFORMATION AND
COMMUNITY PREPAREDNESS
ACTIVITIES. TO IMPROVE COMMUNITY
AWARENESS AND RESILIENCY IN
RESPONSE TO THESE ACTIVITIES.
THE FUNDING WOULD BE USED IN A
pGOVERNMENT PLANNING GRANTS WHERE
WE WOULD PROVIDE OF LEVEL OF
FUNDING TO COUNTIES AND THE
SEVERE.
FIRE THREAT AREAS TO UPDATE THE
ARM THEIR LOCAL EMERGENCY PLANS
TO ADDRESS THE PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUTDOWNS.
THEY COULD ALSO CONVENE REGIONAL
STAKEHOLDERS AND CONDUCT
TRAININGS AND EXERCISES TO
REINFORCE PLANNING ASSUMPTIONS
AS WELL AS EXPLORE WITH THE
UTILITIES THE ESTABLISHMENT OR
EXPANSION.
OF INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY LED
COMMUNITY RESOURCE CENTER
PROGRAMS.
ANOTHER AREA THAT THEY COULD DO
THAT THIS MONEY WOULD BE USED
FOR IS TOO HARD AND STATE OWNED
CRITICAL FACILITIES TO ENSURE
CONTINUITY OF OPERATIONS.
OVER OVER THE PROLONGED POWER
OUTAGES -- WE RECENTLY SURVEYED
VARIOUS STATE AGENCIES TO COME
UP WITH WHAT THEIR NEEDS COULD
BE.
AND WE'RE LOOKING AT NOT JUST
[inaudible]
IMMEDIATE -- PUBLIC SAFETY
RESPONSE AGENCIES BUT AGENCIES
SUCH AS THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION OR THE FISH AND A HALF
BATHS FOOD AND AGRICULTURE.
SO THE VERY STATE AGENCIES WHO
DON'T HAVE THAT BACKUP POWER
NEEDED. TO MAINTAIN SERVICES
DURING ANY TYPE OF SHUTDOWNS ONE
EXAMPLE THAT WE HAD IS THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAS
IDENTIFIED TWO TITLE ONE FOOD
DISTRIBUTION WAREHOUSES.
THAT DON'T HAVE POWER BACK UP
THOSE AREAS IT COULD LEAD -- TO
A LOT OF FOOD GOING BAD AND THE
NEED TO REPLACE THAT
[inaudible]
BERMAN.
ON THIS ONE YOU AS YOU DESCRIBED
IN THE STAFF REPORT SHOWS YOU'VE
MENTIONED [inaudible]
WELL FIRST.
IT'S LEGITIMATE FOR GIVEN WHAT
WE'VE EXPERIENCED SO FAR WITH
THE FIRES AND KNOWING THAT THERE
IS BEEN SOME INVOLVEMENT WITH
OUR POWER LINES.
THAT IS IT APPROPRIATE FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY TWO AT TIMES THE
POWER.
BAND -- IT SO THAT'S YOUR BIG
KNOWLEDGE IN NOW AND THAT'S THE
POINT OF THIS ITEM BUT I NOTE
THAT YOU INDICATE THAT.
THIS FUNDING IN ADDITION TO
BEING ABLE TO SHORE UP THE
CAPACITY FOR A STATE OFFICER AN
OFF AND CAL FIRE -- TO HAVE
POWER IF SUCH AN OUTAGE OCCURS
YOU MENTION VARIOUS OTHER THINGS
LIKE THE ABILITY FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT STAFF PLANNING GRANTS
TO IMPROVE THEIR LOCAL
PREPAREDNESS WHICH MAY.
REQUIRE WHICH WOULD ALLOW THEM
TO IDENTIFY WHAT CRITICAL.
SERVICES THEY MAY BE OPERATING
THAT DON'T HAVE BACKUP POWER --
AND BE ABLE -- TO ADDRESS THAT
AS WE GO FORWARD.
YOU MY SALE THAT.
BECAUSE IT'S ALL LISTED HERE BUT
THEN I NOTED YESTERDAY IN THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE WHEN ASKED
THE QUESTION.
THE ANSWER WAS THAT SEVENTY
MILLION WOULD GO TOWARDS BACKUP
GENERATORS FOR STATE FACILITIES.
AND ONLY FIVE MILLION FOR LOCAL
PLANTS.
AND THAT SEEMED A BIT SKEWED TO
ME WHILE I DO APPRECIATE THAT WE
DO NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
STATE FACILITIES HAVE BACKUP.
WE ALSO KNOW I MEAN ESPECIALLY
WHEN WE MENTION HERE.
THE ISSUE ABOUT LIFE SUSTAINING
EQUIPMENT.
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS TO
OPERATE ON THERE OBVIOUSLY IN
PLACES OTHER THAN OUR FIRE
STATIONS.
SO IT JUST SEEMED A LITTLE
SKEWED [inaudible]
RESPONSE.
A SERVICE TO THE ANSWER THERE SO
OUR PLANNING ASSUMPTION ON THE
LOCAL PLANNING GRANTS.
OF IN IS BUILDING OFF OF THE
LOCAL PLANNING CUT CONTINUE ON
THAT THEY HAVE FOR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE.
SO THE GOAL OF THIS FUNDING WAS
TO PROVIDE.
GRANTS SO THAT THEY COULD
REVISIT THOSE EMERGENCY PLANS IN
THE LIGHT OF THESE EXTENDED
PROLONGED OUTAGES AND BE ABLE TO
CONVENE A MULTI.
THE FACETED STAKEHOLDER GROUPS
INCLUDING REPRESENTATIVES FROM
THE ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS --
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AND
ENSURING THAT THEY'RE WORKING
WITH LOCALLY WITH THEIR NON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS AND
THEIR COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDER
APPRECIATE THAT.
AND I THINK IT'S OBVIOUSLY JUST
SPOKE TO THAT NEED RIGHT WHEN
I'M RACING IS THAT I HAVE A B.
C. P. THAT HAS A LOT OF DETAIL.
OF A LOT OF NEEDS BUT THEN IN
THE ANSWER ATTY ASSEMBLY.
BY WAS.
HEARD.
AND SAW THE THE ANSWER WAS
SEVENTY MILLION WOULD GO TO THE
STATE FACILITIES AND ONLY FIVE
MILLION FOR THESE LOCAL NATURE
DESCRIBING SO IS THAT YOUR
INTENTION.
A THAT WAS A PLANNING ASSUMPTION
THAT WENT INTO THE PART OF IT IS
SORT OF A WHY ALL THE LANGUAGE
AROUND ALL THESE OTHER NEEDS
WHEN IN FACT REALLY THE MAJORITY
DID NOT I MEAN THE MAJORITY I
MEAN THAT.
FINDING IS GOING TO GO FORWARD
THE STATE AGENCY I JUST THINK
IT'S A MORE ACCURATE DEPICTION
OF WHAT WE'RE BEING ASKED TO
APPROVE.
WELL SO AS I MENTIONED BUILDING
ON WHAT THE LOCALS ARE ALREADY-DOING IN REGARD TO THEIR LOCAL
PLANNING THIS WAS A WAY TO HAVE
THEM ASSESS THAT AND BE ABLE TO
TRAIN AND EXERCISE AND I GUESS
VALIDATE THOSE PLANNING
ASSUMPTIONS FOR THESE PROLONGED
OUTAGES.
AND THEN KNOWING THAT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT'S ON HOME THOSE LOCAL
DEPEND -- FOR SUSTAINABLE
SERVICES -- ARE READY TO ALSO
ADDRESS THEIR FIRST RESPONDER
CAPABILITIES THERE ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO SUPPORT THE
LOCALS SO -- KNOWING THAT SOME
OF THE CRITICAL THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE TO HARD IN THOSE
FACILITIES WILL COST MORE THAN
AND THEN AND THEN PERHAPS FROM
THOSE PLANNING FROM THAT.
THOSE LOCAL EFFORTS SEEING WHAT
COMES OUT OF THOSE -- THOSE
REGIONAL EFFORTS TRAINING AND
EXERCISES FAR AS WHAT'S NEEDED --
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
CENTER MOORLACH I THINK I JUST
WANT TO FOLLOW UP WITH WHAT
YOU'RE.
ASKING STE MADAM CHAIR THAT IS --
THIS MONEY THAT GOES TO THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
IS THAT A GRANT IS IT ALONE YEAH.
SO WHAT WE HAVE IS WE HAVE A
MODEL THAT WE USE UNDER OUR
VICTIM SERVICES SIDE WHERE WAS A
PLANNING GRANT.
THAT WENT TO THE LOCA
GOVERNMENT TO CONVENE A MULTI
AGENCY STAKEHOLDER GROUPS THAT
REALLY -- DOVE INTO A PARTICULAR
IN THE SPIN THAT CASE IT WAS OF
A ON REPRESENTED GROUPS AND
VICTIM A SERVICES IN THIS CASE
IT WOULD BE A SIMILAR MODEL
WHERE THESE PLANNING GRANTS.
BASED UPON REIMBURSEMENT AND AND
AT WHAT THEY USE WHETHER WAS
TRAINING EXERCISE PLANNING --
WORKSHOPS THOSE LOCAL EVENTS OF
THEIR OF THE GRANT PROGRAM WOULD
HAVE THAT CRITERIA AND THEN IT-WOULD GO TO THE LOCALS AND THEN
THEY WOULD REPORT BACK AND BE
ABLE TO USE THOSE MONEY.
AND THEM AND THE MONEY WOULD BE
PROVIDED.
SO THEY CAN SCORE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR.
IN MADAM CHAIR IF I MAY YES --
JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT.
TYPICALLY WE WOULD PROVIDE MORE
BACK UP -- THIS IS.
A KIND OF A NEW AREA THAT WE'RE
IN WITH THE PUBLIC -- CITY POWER
SHUT OFFS -- THE LANGUAGE.
IN THE BUDGET ACT.
SIMILAR TO THE SUB COMMITTEE --
DOES PROVIDE A BIT OF
FLEXIBILITY -- WE ALSO.
THE AGENDA NOTES THAT VISUAL
LANGUAGE LANGUAGE WILL BE ADDED
TO REPORT BACK TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE -- SO.
WELL THERE ISN'T MUCH QUIRK
CLARITY RIGHT NOW IN MUCH DETAIL --
WORK REALLY AND EXTRAORDINARY
TIMES WITH -- THESE IDEAS ABOUT
US YES WE ARE TIED TO IT.
I THINK A REALLY RAISING IS THAT
I HAVEN'T I HVE MATERIAL FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION THAT
DESCRIBES A NUMBER OF VERY
IMPORTANT PURPOSES. FOR SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR ASK BUT WHEN
DRILL DOWN WE FIND THAT. SEVENTY
MILLION OF IT GOES TO ONE OF THE
DESCRIBED THIS IS AN ONLY FIVE
MILLION TO A WHOLE NUMBER OF
OTHER DESCRIBED PURPOSES SO THAT
IS REALLY THE ISSUE FOR ME.
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY THAT.
IT.
THAT THE STATE DOESN'T NEED THE
SEVENTY MILLION FOR OUR STATE
FACILITIES IT'S MORE THAT.
HOW DO I EVALUATE WHAT YOU
REALLY HAVE IN MIND WHEN I'M
BEING GIVEN A LOT OF RATIONALE
FOR AN EXPENDITURE BUT THEN I
FIND OUT THAT REALLY THAT
RATIONAL ONLY APPLIES?
TO THIS MUCH OF THE EXPENDITURE
AND THE OTHER RATIONALE.
APPLIES TO THAT MUCH.
GO AHEAD MADAM CHAIR I JUST LIKE
IT MAYBE CLARIFY A LITTLE BIT
FURTHER WE WE SPOKE WITH THE
DIRECTIONAL AFTER AT THE
ASSEMBLY HEARING AND WE'VE HAD
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS AT WITHIN
THE MINISTRATION I JUST WOULD
LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THAT.
WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW IS KIND OF
INFORMATION GATHERING AND THE
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS FIGURE
IS KIND OF A AN ATTEMPTED
ASSESSING.
WHAT THE NEEDS ARE CROSSED
PUBLIC SAFETY INFRASTRUCTURE
EIGHT WITHIN THE STATE SO THAT
THE I DON'T I DON'T THINK WE'RE
AT A POINT HOLDEN NOT PUBLIC
SAFETY INFRASTRUCTURE UP AND
DOWN THE STATE?
STATE.
FACILITIES YES STATE STATE
INSTITUTIONS STATE FACILITIES.
WHERE THERE ARE GAPS IN NEEDS
THERE?
I DON'T THINK WE'RE AT A POINT
NOW WE'RE SAYING THAT OF THE
SEVENTY FIVE WE'RE GOING TO
SPEND SEVENTY OF IT ON THAT.
I THINK WE'RE STILL IN THE
PROCESS OF DOING IS IDENTIFYING
WHERE ALL THE GAPS IN NEEDS ARE
AND THE INITIAL GRANTS THAT GO
TO THE COUNTIES WE'LL BE
TOGETHER SIMILAR INFORMATION
FROM THEIR SIDE.
THE IDEA WITH THE PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE IS TO HAVE A FLEXIBLE
PART OF MONEY SO THAT.
AS THESE EVENTS START HAPPENING
AND WE KNOW WHICH REGIONS ARE
GOING TO BE HIT THE HEAVIEST AND
WHAT -- GAPS ARE KIND OF THE
MOST VULNERABLE THAT WE CAN
INVEST IN IN THOSE GAPS.
AND THAT WILL BE A MIX I THINK
OF BOTH STATE AND LOCAL OF
PUBLIC SAFETY INFRASTRUCTURE I
JUST I THINK RIGHT NOW WE'RE
GOING OFF OF EARLY INFORMATION
YAK IS IS WE MENTIONED THAT THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT'S KIND OF
SOMEWHAT NEW AND EVOLVING AND
WE'RE TRYING TO GATHER RELEVANT.
INFORMATION SO WE KNOW THE
BREADTH AND DEPTH OF OUR OWN
ABILITIES -- AND I THINK THE
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS
TESTIFIED TO IN THE ASSEMBLY IS
TO SAY THIS IS WHAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED FOR STATE INSTITUTION.
GAPS RIGHT NOW AND WE KNOW THAT
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO DO SOME
GRANTS FOR INITIAL STUDIES IN
ASSESSMENTS AT A LOCAL LEVEL.
THAT'S WHAT WE KNOW RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T THINK WE CAN SAY
DEFINITIVELY THE SPLIT IS GOING
TO BE SEVENTY AND FIVE I THINK
ONCE WE GATHER MORE INFORMATION
TO SOME OF THE GRANT TO GET SOME
MORE INFORMATION.
ON THESE EVENTS ACTUALLY START
HAPPENING WE CAN BE MORE
TARGETED.
THAN HOLD KNOW A WHOLE LOT MORE
ABOUT HOW IT GETS USED I WAS
JUST KIND OF THE NAY.
SKEWS ME THE NATURE OF OUR EARLY
THIS IS AN IN OFFICE WE NEED A
LOT MORE INFORMATION I THINK TO
MAKE DECISIONS ON THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE ALL OF THAT --
BEFORE THE BUDGETS ENACTED.
THERE ARE MORE LOOK THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND BRINGS UP A
POINT THAT I MAYBE WHEN I JUST.
ADDRESS NOW.
IN THAT IS.
A LACK OF INFORMATION OR
VAGUENESS ON A NUMBER OF ITEMS
IN TODAY'S AGENDA -- SO YOU
MIGHT FIND ME VOTING NO JUST
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE IT ALL AND
I CAN'T MAKE A DECISION I WANT
TO THANK MATT OSTERLEY MY
CONSULTANT FOR EMAIL AND YOU
HAVE TO ONE AM.
I'M SURE YOU GUYS WERE UP ALL
NIGHT.
TOO SO IT GETS WILL DIFFICULT
WHEN IT JUST KIND OF COMES FREE
MATCH AT THE LAST MINUTE SO.
I'M NOT TRYING TO BE OBSTINATE
JUST KIND OF FEELING LIKE.
HOW DO YOU MAKE AN INTELLIGENT
DECISION WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE?
EVERYTHING THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
POINT.
HI I'M PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE
SIDE OF A NEW CAR WENT ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES -- VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS BUT WITH
THE CHAIR INDIO ASK -- IN WOULD --
WOULD ONE EMPHASIZED THAT YOU
KNOW AS IS VALUATIONS ARE
POTENTIALLY GOING ON THAT -- THE
MONEY IN THIS PA WOULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO COUNTY GOVERNMENTS
TO DO PLANNING PREPAREDNESS AND
ALSO -- TO INCREASE RECENTLY
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE WORKING WITH PRETTY
pDEFINITELY ENCOURAGE THAT --
MOVING FORWARD THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT.
EARLIER DID YOU HAVE A COMMENT.
EASY I'M.
HUNGRY IN THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE -- WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS IN CONCERT DEFINITELY
MAKES SENSE -- CERTAINLY THERE
ARE SOME SIGNIFICANT HEALTH AND
SAFETY CONCERNS RELATED TO POWER
SHUT OFFS -- HOWEVER WE BROUGHT
UP I'D JUST SOME KIND SOME
GENERAL -- COMMENTS ABOUT THE
LACK OF CLARITY ON THE THE
SPECIFIC USES OF THE FUNDS AND
ALSO HOW ARE WE AS WE COORDINATE
WITH INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES
WHO MIGHT BE DOING.
SOME ACTIVITIES ALSO AROUND
POWER SHUT OFF AND SO WE'D SAID
THAT -- TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS TO PURSUE THIS --
APPROACH IN THIS GENERAL CONCEPT --
A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS THAT
COULD THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER -- ONE OF THOSE IS
BUDGET BILLING WHICH THAT WOULD
PRIORITIZE THE USE OF THOSE
FUNDS ARE FOR EXAMPLE OF THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE TO GO TO LOCALS
VERSES -- THE STATE THAT COULD
BE PROVIDED AS PART OF THE
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE THAT YOU
APPROVED -- YOU COULD PROVIDE
THAT PROVIDE FUNDING FOR A MORE
LIMITED DURATION JUST NINETEEN
TWENTY FOR EXAMPLE WITH SOME
REPORTING BACK ON THEN YOU'D
HAVE A SENSE OF HOW THAT MONEY
IS -- EXPECTED TO GO OUT AND AND
IS ACTUALLY GOING OUT BEFORE
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL FUNDING --
OR YOU COULD MAKE THE FUNDING --
AVAILABLE PROVISIONALLY BASED ON
THE SUBMISSION OF A MORE
DETAILED REPORTS OF THOSE ARE A
FEW OPTIONS THAT WE LAY OUT --
NOT NECESSARILY MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE BUT WE DO THINK IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT PURPOSE IT'S
JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS -- OVERSIGHT
AND THAT THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
PROVIDES ENOUGH INFORMATION THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CAN MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS.
YES I AM A I AM SOMEWHAT
STRUGGLING WITH THE THE MOTION I
WOULD LIKE -- TO BECAUSE THIS.
FIVE I TOTALLY SEE THE NEED.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT WE DON'T
FULLY HAVE THE INFO YET AND THE
PART OF ACTING ON THIS IS IT
WILL ALLOW -- YES TO GET SOME OF
THE INFO IT'S JUST HARD TO SAY
YES TO SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
WITHOUT REALLY HAVING
UNDERSTANDING YET OF HOW I MEAN
THERE COULD BE THAT.
POTENTIALLY THAT OUR OWN STATE
OFFICES NEED MORE THAN THAT FOR
THIS ABILITY TO DEAL WITH --
BACKUP POWER OR MAYBE A LOT LESS --
YOU KNOW DON'T KNOW -- SO RIGHT
NOW THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
WOULD BE PLACE HOLDER BUDGET
APPROVING WITH PLACE HOLDER
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE.
REPORTING USES OF THE FUNDING --
THAT WOULD INFORMACIóN HOURS
USED BUT IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
PUT IN [inaudible]
THE CONTINGENCY OF SOME OF ALL
OF FUNDING BASED ON THE
SUBMISSION OF MORE DETAIL -- I
DON'T WANT TO FILL UP THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE AGENDA PER
SE BUT I WONDER IF -- IF MY
COLLEAGUES WOULD BE MORE
COMFORTABLE IF WE APPROVED IT
BUT ASKED FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
TO COME BACK WITH THE DETAIL
WITH BY A CERTAIN POINT.
OKAY IN WE COULD GIVE YOU KNOW
HAVE A HEALTHY AMOUNT OF TIME
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY IS COLLECTING
INFORMATION SO WE WOULDN'T HAVE
TO FREEZE THE SPENDING.
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY WE'RE ABOUT TO
START FIRE SEASON.
BUT WE COULD -- YOU KNOW PERHAPS
SOME OF THEIR PROVE THE FULL
AMOUNT BUT ALLOW FOR ONE HALF TO
BE SPENT IN A WITHOUT
RESTRICTION.
AND THE OTHER HALF.
BASED ON THAT BEFORE IT SPENT
THAT THE REPORT COMES BACK AS TO
HOW IT HOW YOU INTEND TO SPEND.
INTERNET TO FACTOR IN THE FACT
THAT WE'RE ABOUT TO START FIRE
SEASON.
YEAH DO YOU MIND.
OKAY [inaudible]
RIGHT.
WITH THAT WILL A DO A ROLL CALL.
CENTER SKINNER.
BY A REMARK HUNDRED ABOUT
[inaudible]
OKAY -- THAT CONCLUDES OUR THE
PORTION AROUND THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES.
AND NOW WE WILL GO -- TO PART B..
WHICH IS THE R. C. C. R. THE OJ
JUDICIAL THOSE AGENCIES THAT ARE
UNDER US.
AND WE HAVE.
A NUMBER OF VOTE ONLY ITEMS.
WE'VE GUIDE -- ISSUE ONE THROUGH.
ALL THE WAY THROUGH ISSUE.
FORTY RIGHT NOW THAT ARE
PROPOSED TO BE.
VOTE ONLY -- AND I DON'T HAVE
ANY -- CHANGES ON ANY OF THOSE --
BUT I WILL -- I WILL TAKE
MOTIONS IN GROUPINGS IN ORDER.
TO ALLOW FOR SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES.
TO RECORD THEIR VOTES IN WAYS
THEY PREFER -- ALL RIGHT SO
WE'RE GONNA.
HOW ABOUT -- LET'S ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON ISSUES ONE THROUGH.
THREE TO APPROVE AS THE STAFF
RECOMMENDED IS THERE A MOTION ON
ISSUES.
ONE THREE THREE WHO [inaudible]
GREAT -- ROLL CALL PLEASE.
CENTER SKINNER I CENTER MORE
LOCK.
CENTER ABOUT.
OKAY.
NOW WE WILL DO -- A VOTE ON A
RATHER I WOULD LIKE TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION.
ON ISSUES -- FOR THREE TWELVE
FOR THE YOU'RE RIGHT -- WE'D
LIKE TO DO YOU A I'D ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON ISSUES FOR THROUGH
[inaudible]
ELEVEN GREAT.
SO THOSE ARE ASKED THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IN THE MATERIALS.
OKAY ROLL CALL.
CENTER SKINNER ISENATOR MORLOCK.
CENTER ABOUT.
OKAY THEN ON ISSUE.
TWELVE LET'S HOLD THAT TO THE IN.
CASE WE'RE GONNA POLISH YOU
TWELVE RIGHT NOW AND VOTE ON IT
SEPARATELY AT THE END OF THESE
.
OKAY AND BY CAN ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON ISSUES THIRTEEN AND
FOURTEEN EXCELLENT THIRTEEN AND
FOURTEEN ROLL CALL.
CENTER SKINNER AYE STERN MORLOCK
CENTER BELL.
OKAY THERE ARE LIKE.
TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON ISSUES
FIFTEEN THROUGH [inaudible]
SEVENTEEN SIX KURT.
RIGHT FIFTY THREE SIXTEEN MOTION.
ROLL CALL AND IT'S ON THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE MATERIALS.
CENTER SKINNER HI CENTER MORE
LOCK [inaudible]
CENTRE BELL [inaudible]
OKAY -- CERTAINLY BECAUSE
THERE'S JUST A LACK OF LANGUAGE
I TYPED I'M JUST GONNA NOT VOTER
NUMBER [inaudible]
SEVENTY FIVE OKAY.
NO WORRIES SO WHATEVER MOTION ON
SEVENTEEN AND ROLL CALL.
CENTER SKINNER FIVE CENTER MORE
LOCKED [inaudible]
CENTRE BELL [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
AND A IF I MAY ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON ISSUE [inaudible]
EIGHTEEN SOME [inaudible]
ROLLCALL.
CENTER SKINNER I CENTER MORE
WALKING OVER SENATOR BELL.
VERY NARROW AND LIKE TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON ISSUES
NINETEEN THROUGH [inaudible]
TWENTY OKAY.
THAT'S NINETEEN TO A YES.
SENATOR BILL MOST.
ITEMS.
TWENTY IS SUBJECT TO THE FINAL
[inaudible]
LEGISLATION.
THIS IS GOING TO BE HERE THIS IS.
NOT WITH REGARD OF EXPENDITURES
IT SAYS.
TO ON THE TRAINING.
THE TO THE RECOMMENDATION FORCES
APPROVED IS BUDGETED BUT HIGH --
CAN WILL ALREADY PREDICT THAT IT
WILL GO TO CONFERENCE BECAUSE
THE ASSEMBLY ACTION WAS
DIFFERENT.
SO THEN THERE WILL BE DISCUSSION
AND ON THE USE OF FORCE TRAINING.
THE SUB IT WILL BE S..
THE LEGISLATION. TO FUND
WHATEVER CERTAINLY THAT WILL BE
A PART OF THAT CONFERENCE
DISCUSSION BECAUSE THE ASSEMBLY
ACTION GOT IT YEAH.
THE TOY MURDER.
OKAY.
ALRIGHT SO THAT IS -- THESE ARE
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
NINETEEN AND TWENTY WHICH ARE
APPROVED IS BUDGETED ROLL CALL.
CENTER SKINNER HI CENTER MORE
LOCK SENATOR BELL [inaudible]
THREE WHAT NOW TO DO TWENTY ONE
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
TWENTY FOUR GREAT -- WHEN
[inaudible]
YEAH.
LET'S TO ROLL CALL ON THOSE.
ITEMS TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY FOUR
CENTER SKINNER HI CENTER MORE
LOCK NO CENTER BELL [inaudible]
OKAY.
AND NOW A MOTION ON ITEM.
TWENTY SIX ISSUE.
TWENTY SIX TWENTY FIVE VOTED I
SKIPPED TWENTY FIVE APOLOGIES --
SO WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS HOLD
THAT ONE ALSO TO THE END.
WHICH IS SO THAT'S WHY I JUST
DIDN'T SAY THAT THAT WAS SILLY
OF ME SO TWELVE AND TWENTY FIVE
OR NUMBER A THE END.
AND WHAT WE'LL DO NOW IS
ENTERTAINING MOTION ON TWENTY
SIX WE HAVE A ROLL CALL ON THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION FOR ISSUE.
TWENTY SIX CENTER SKINNER HI
CENTER MORE LOCK OF CENTRE BELL
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
I AM NOW I DO I'D ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON ITEMS TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY NINE AND
THIRTY AND THOSE ARE AS THE
STAFF RECOMMENDED.
SOME.
OKAY ROLL CALL ON THOSE.
CENTER SKINNER I CENTER MOCK
CENTRE BELL [inaudible]
OKAY -- AND THEN I WOULD LIKE TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON ISSUE
[inaudible]
THIRTY ONE ROLL CALL.
CENTER SKINNER I CENTER MORE
LOCK.
SENATE BILL [inaudible]
OKAY.
NOW I'D LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON ISSUES 323-334-3530
SIX AND THIRTY SEVEN AGAIN IS
WOULD BE AS STAFF RECOMMENDATION.
IN THE MATERIALS.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
BROUGHT.
CENTER SKINNER BY SENATOR MORE
LOCK SENATOR BELL.
OKAY THEN I WOULD LIKE TO
ENTERTAIN MOTION ON A SINGLE
ITEM ITEM.
THIRTY EIGHT AGAIN AS THE STAFF
IS RECOMMENDED.
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION LET'S TO
ROLL CALL.
CENTER SKINNER.
I CENTER MORE LOCK CENTER BELL.
RIGHT NOW I LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON ITEMS THIRTY NINE AND
FORTY AS STAFF RECOMMENDED OKAY
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THIRTY NINE
OF FORTY STAFF RECOMMENDATION
FOR ALL CALL.
CENTER SKINNER HI CENTER MORE
LOCK ON SENATOR BILL.
OKAY SO LET'S SEE NOW ACT ON
ISSUE [inaudible]
TWELVE AND CAPITAL OUTLAY --
THERE'S A LOT OF ITEMS IN THE
CAPITAL OUTLAY [inaudible]
AND A SENATOR MORE LARK IF YOU
ORDER.
I ITEM TWELVE MINIATURE TWELVE
HAS A NUMBER OF ITEMS I'D LIKE
TO HOLD NUMBER SIX FOR SEPARATE
VOTE.
AND I BELIEVE THE NUMBER
SEVENTEEN BUT IF YOU COULD JUST
GIVE ME A SECOND OKAY.
NO WORRIES FOR YEAR.
THE NUMBERS YET NUMBER SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN FOR THE TWO I'D.
LIKE TO PULL [inaudible]
SO ON THE ITEM THAT.
THE NUMBER OF CAPITAL OUTLAY --
ISSUES THAT WE WOULD APPROVED.
I WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
APPROVE ALL OF THE CAPITAL
OUTLAYS.
LISTED IN THE ITEM WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF THE THE CELL DOOR
RETROFIT.
AT THE SOLAR DAD FACILITY.
AND WITH THE HEALTH CARE
FACILITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM
LEASE REVENUE APPROPRIATION.
SO SOME OF RIGHT TO A MOTION ON
EVERYTHING BUT THOSE TWO THAT I
MENTIONED.
AND ROLL CALL.
CENTER SKINNER I CENTER MORE
LOCK.
I CENTER BELL.
OKAY.
AND THE I WOULD LIKE TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION. FOR ITEM SIX THE
TRAINING FACILITY CELL DOORS AN
ITEM.
SEVENTEEN THE HEALTH CARE
FACILITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
WHAT DO ROLL CALL?
CENTER SKINNER I CENTER MODOC OF
CENTER BELL.
OKAY SO THAT.
DEALS WITH THEIR CAPITAL OUTLAY.
AND THEN WE WILL GO TO ISSUE --
TWENTY FIVE AND SENATOR MORE
LARK I BELIEVE YOU'D LIKE.
TO SPLIT THE MOTION INTO TO
MOTIONS SHE KNOWS [inaudible]
PLEASE.
I LIKE THIS FOR THE VOTER VOTE I
I'M HAPPY TO APPROVE THE FUNDING
BUT I'D LIKE TO LAY OFF ON THE
TRAILER BILL AND ALRIGHT SO THE
OUR MOTION BEFORE US IS.
TO APPROVE THE FUNDING FOR THE
TWENTY FIVE TRIAL COURT
JUDGESHIPS MOVED.
AND WILL DO A ROLL CALL.
CENTERS SKINNER AYE CINEMA Là.
SENATOR BELL.
A NOW I'D LIKE A MOTION ON THE
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL IT'S
IT'S A PLACE HOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD DETAIL THE
METHODOLOGY FOR THE ALLOCATION
OF THE JUDGESHIPS.
RIGHT SO WE HAVE THAT MOTION
BEFORE US.
AND WHAT DO A ROLL CALL.
CENTERS SKINNER.
BY SENATOR MODOC [inaudible]
SENATE ABOUT [inaudible]
EXCELLENT -- THE MOTION PASSES A
CASE THAT WE HAVE NOW DONE ALL
OF OUR VOTE ONLY ITEMS
[inaudible]
AND THOSE WERE OUR ONLY ITEMS
WHEN YOU KNOW PUBLIC COMMENT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- MARKET PRAY I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CITIES FOR SELF RELIANCE JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY -- THEY ARE H.
POWERS AUTHORITY MADE UP OF
SEVEN CITIES IN LA COUNTY.
THAT ARE HOSTING -- OR HOST --
CARD ROOMS IN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR PREVIOUSLY CHEN
DIVING A DISCUSSION ITEM -- ON
THE BUREAU'S PROPOSED ACTION TO
REMOVE APPROVALS OF PRIOR
APPROVED GAMES GAMES THAT HAVE
BEEN APPROVED FOR MORE THAN.
TWENTY YEARS WE ALSO WANT TO
BRING TO THE COMMITTEE'S
ATTENTION THIS MORNING -- THE
RELEASE OF A STATE AUDIT.
OF THE BUREAU OF GAMBLING
CONTROL -- WHICH FOUND THAT THE
COMMISSION THAT THE BUREAU AND
COMMISSION HAVE NOT INSURED.
THAT THERE REGULATION AND
PRACTICES TREAT ALL APPLICANTS
CONSISTENTLY AND FAIRLY.
THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH OUR
OBSERVATION AND IN A LETTER
DATED JUNE APRIL TWENTY SIX BY
GUARDINO MAYOR TASHA SERVE THE
TO ATTORNEY GENERAL BUT SERRA.
IT POINTED POINTS OUT THAT MANY
TRIBES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
OPERATE GAMES IN PLAIN SIGHT
WITHIN THEIR GAMING HALLS IN
CLEAR VIOLATION OF THEIR
COMPACTS WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
YET THE BUREAU CHOOSES TO
CONSIDER ROOM BOOKING PRIOR
APPROVED GAMES YET NOT GOING
AFTER THIS.
BLATANT PRACTICE OF ILLEGAL
GAMING AND SO WE THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THAT. TO YOU -- WE'VE
HAD A CHANCE TO ONLY REVIEW THAT --
THAT ON IT BRIEFLY WANTED TO
BRING THAT TO YOUR ATTENTION AS
YOU CONTINUE TO ENGAGE IN THE
REVIEW OF THE BUDGETS OF THE
COMMISSION AND THE BUREAU OF
GAMING CONTROL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT.
SENATOR SKINNER MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE I WANT TO THANK YOU ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON ACCESS TO JUSTICE.
FOR YOUR APPROVAL OF ITEM TWENTY
THREE I'M RON ROBY.
ASSOCIATE JUSTICE OF THE COURT
OF APPEAL IN SACRAMENTO IN THE
FORMER -- CHAIR OF THE
COMMISSION AND THAT ITEM WAS
VERY IMPORTANT.
AND THE APPROVAL OF THE FUNDING
FOR LEGAL SERVICES EQUALLY
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
RECOMMENDATION VOTE.
THANK YOU NEXT A GOOD MORNING
I'M STEVE AUSTIN A JUDGE IN
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND FORMER
CHAIR OF THE ACCESS TO JUSTICE
COMMISSION AS WELL WHEN ECHO
JUSTICE ROBIE'S COMMENTS AND
THANK -- THE CHAIR THANK STAFF --
FOR AND THE COMMITTEE GENERAL
FOR PASSAGE OF THE THE THE
FUNDING THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR SKINNER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
STAFF I WANT TO I'M KATHERINE
BLAKE FOR I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
DISABILITY RACE CALIFORNIA LEGAL
AID PROGRAM AND VICE CHAIR OF
THE ACCESS COMMISSION.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORTOF ALL OF THE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE ITEMS IN THAT PACKAGE
AND PARTICULARLY FOR LEGAL AID
FOR THE ACCESS COMMISSION THANK
YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE GERRY SMITH ON BEHALF
OF THE NEARLY ONE HUNDRED
MEMBERS OF THE LEGAL AID
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
ECHOING MY COLLEAGUES COMMENTS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON
ITEM.
TWENTY THREE A PROVIDING THE
FUNDING FOR ACCESS TO JUSTICE
AND FOR THE WEEKLY COMMUNITY.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBER THE K. I LIKE
THIS NEW LOOK TO THIS IS GREAT --
MICHAEL WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY -- AND WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE THE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE PACKAGE WITH PARTICULAR
FOCUS ON THE EQUAL ACCESS
FUNDING IN THE IN THE PROPOSAL
HOPE THAT IT STAYS IN THE BUDGET
THIS YEAR THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS NO I BOTTOM
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THE COLLECTORS FOR JUSTICE FUNDS
NEXUS TO JUSTICE IN THE
PLACEHOLDER.
CURRENT BILLING WHICH TO BE
FORTHCOMING THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE -- BRENDA
ALISON ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES.
PLEASE FORGIVE ME I NEED TO GET
TOP BROKERS ARE RAN OVER HERE --
BUT WE ARE PLEASED. TO SUPPORT --
THE STATE APPROPRIATIONS
PLUMMETED JUST MET.
THIS MAN REFERENCE SO I'VE
REFERENCE TO THE COURT BUDGET AS
WELL AS THE TARGETED
AUGMENTATION OF TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR COURT CLERKS -- AND
INVESTIGATORS BELIEVE HE'S A
CRITICAL CLASSIFICATIONS THAT WE
NEED TO SEE INVESTMENT SENT TO
HELP RESTORE ACCESS TO JUSTICE
AND COMMUNITY CENTER.
AND TRIAL COURSE THAT HAVE BEEN
DESPERATELY CUT.
DURING THE ECONOMIC DOWNTURN WE
THINK THE STATE APPROPRIATIONS
LIMóN ADJUSTMENT IS APPROPRIATE --
THIS IS A OF FINANCIAL TOOL THAT
PROVIDES A LITTLE BIT OF A
CUSHION TO COURSE IT ALSO PUT --
YOU KNOW COURSE IN A BETTER.
FISCAL POSITION WITH RESPECT TO
BARGAINING AS WE KNOW COURSE
HAVE TO MAKE A VERY SERIOUS.
DECISIONS AS IN RESPECT TO THE
SERVICES THAT THEY OFFER HOW
MANY WORKERS TODAY CAN EMPLOY WE
BELIEVE THAT JUST APPROVING TOOL --
AND WE APPLAUD THE SUBCOMMITTEE
FOR TAKEN -- THE LEAD ON SUCH A
CRITICAL PIECE -- I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE COMPS OF
COMMITTEES -- RECOGNITION OF A
SEVERE -- THE FUNDING ISSUE THAT
WE HAVE WITH RESPECT TO A COURT
REPORTER SO -- AND WE APPLAUD
THE COMMITTEES -- DECISION TO
INCLUDE FUNDING OFFER THOSE
WORKERS AS WELL -- AND I'D ALSO
LIKE -- TO SEND -- MY SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF MACHEL CAPTURE FROM
THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION ON THE STOCK
ON THESE TOPICS AS WELL -- BUT
WILL RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS ARE
THE INCLUSION OF THIS AND
ADVOCACY FROM MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE -- TO LARGER BUDGET
COMMITTEE AS WELL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
WITH THAT.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE MIND
THE PUBLIC SAFETY AND THE
JUDICIARY.
WILL NOW ADJOURN